hello wind welcome to studio 10 grand
master plum cars ed plumb Kelly do is
that do some Popovich from Serbia ok so
I'm King zinan my usual age 3 Lyle
gather sister this is a main main line
98 ok do a coffee shop g3 he might have
bishop age 60 interesting ok I'll go
here first looking at them f5 square ok
so does he have some e for business here
for a pin maybe he has right GXE for
might be might be possible yeah but I
don't really I don't have an another
move here I have to play it ok now with
this it wasn't exactly what I wanted ok
night cheeks
that's Bishop c35 immediately let's ban
okay not good not good at all
yeah so something I did something wrong
them 23 I think it's still normal that
may be Bishop d3 in it's not a good idea
your black is far more far too active
then I like I mean it's not like I'm
losing or so but it's definitely not
what it should be that's not what you
want it can do things on the G file yeah
I'm not sure about 93 and this position
is something that you can do I am unsure
if it if it helps much can also play
yeah this move yeah I don't think I can
allow a three so I have to have to do
this
maybe this is not so bad um III III is
the idea okay i can go Bishop e3 kind of
going towards the endgame yeah I mean as
III a threatened maybe I have to land
game doesn't look very threatening check
yeah I'm putting the d3 pawn right I
know you can take them yeah it's still
not a big deal is rook e8 yeah I'm
getting there slowly so 94 now could not
you five though let's go let's go for it
so
ruki 8 i've got 95 to e6 I'm not really
threatening d3 I think sop8 is always
very bad pin but 95 it's something
hmm it's not easy for black I guess yeah
I went that way maybe he can't Bishop
age no I've got Bishop deform okay some
Bishop f6 he can take only 3 Bishop h6
mate but half H for it shouldn't be know
that I can take some kind of slip on run
Black Rose is what do you want to do
here don't understand the mouth slip
here what was the idea huh hard to tell
i thought i did it must be some kind of
mouse slip or whatever he says unclear
should be okay for me yeah possible yeah
yeah it's I said possibly possible but
it's not easy to play it really isn't I
have no idea actually what what's going
on 96 is an idea here his many he's got
many options in the computer wants to
take and go see 5 which is not something
I'm expected at all this also looks very
strange like check to allow this but
probably I have no good move now yeah I
don't have a good mood this is looking
uncomfortable yeah but ok this is slide
is kind of kind of weird anyway yeah but
what is he doing here Bishop takes his
rear that said looks a little bit weird
hmm
tough to say how he try if he develops I
mean sisters look bad right hard to say
though really I would like to check the
opening amount of course I wasn't this
is I think kind of normal between the
three back yeah maybe maybe Bishop d3
isn't great I mean somehow it felt like
I was right I was running into this a
little bit okay the engine wants to do
this takes I'm gonna let this green in
three and then long okay that's
interesting that's interesting what
about this also cancels long interesting
play it is because this this is great
for watching okay yeah cannot take the
Queen oops checkmate hmm that's very
cute yes maybe maybe this is better i
don't know and this is a played pretty
automatically but after you fought he
definitely is good yeah the engine check
gives this is better antiques yes hmm
yeah i was thinking Bishop e3 but Bishop
f5 and then castles long yeah it's
probably good for black computers not
giving a clear assessment yeah those
positions are I just a notoriously murky
and here you know computers on about
equal it very tough very tough to say I
didn't didn't feel so well here but it's
maybe not not totally bad okay well
thanks for watching